[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to happy game
oh yeah good idea
time for a nice relaxing sleep
if you don't know about this game
it's got some pretty trippy visuals that
i saw on the store page
and uh
yeah just wait for it
it'll show itself to you
[Music]
oh no
well this is a sudden shift in an abrupt
entrance into this game
[Music]
don't trust that
down down down saving
did you just save
[Music]
what
ah i
see i can't move
therefore i must move the present
[Music]
man kid you really want this trust me
hmm
hi kitty
oh hi clowny
and the third
oh
hi cloudy
that's a fun clown
oh
excuse me
oh bye clowny
hi clowny
[Music]
hi
how you doing man this has just been the
best birthday ever i can't wait to see
what comes next hey
interesting
oh
fun
do i want to pull on that yes i do
it's a bell
oh my
god oh my god
what are we doing
and why are we doing it
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
well i didn't mean to do this unless it
was good thing then i totally meant it
and i take all the credit
[Applause]
[Music]
kid i would not be happy about anything
in this place i would not think that
anything is good here oh maybe it is
maybe i was wrong
oh that's lovely
oh no
don't you dare
[Music]
oh my god
yeah
oh oh i get it i'm supposed to i want
the ball i want the ball so badly i just
want the ball that's all i've ever
wanted was the ball
[Music]
oh
i
really i know this is quite abrupt into
this game but legitimately you're on the
same level of understanding as i am this
is trippy and weird
oh
yeah i think oh
i don't like it when you clap
okay
oh
oh you want that oh you wanted that oh
you actually wanted that
hang on
it's like ah what if i
ah
perfect
hang on hang on hang on
man these psychic powers of yours getter
pretty amazing
are you telling me to leave
is that what you're saying you're
telling me to leave right now and what
what happens if i don't
[Music]
oh
oh wait
[Music]
i'm gonna go i uh i think i might have
screwed it up a little bit i don't know
what the
wait wow well
well well maybe
maybe there's something else that i need
over here and i can come back for it and
i don't know
oh
well i don't like the look of that
[Music]
oh no
i think that was a monkey head
okay hold on now
ah
yeah you hold on to that kiddo yeah you
hold on to that real tight yeah that's
gonna come in high
just gonna plop that on there
oh
[Music]
long
long is this important about the ball
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah if it wasn't clear pay attention to
the epilepsy warning at the beginning of
this video okay
um
well i didn't do this this was not my
fault
this was clearly hedonism in work
ah ball oh good yeah just carry on leave
whatever destruction you had you done
left behind you don't even need to worry
about it that's in the past
[Music]
that's so far back in the not now
hi pig
[Music]
what is that about oh
crank
clunk chunker
oh wow
it's oh it's oh
it's like a jack
oh boy
oh yeah
hi
oh no
no
[Music]
okay
oh good
[Music]
how do i explain this to anybody how are
any of you gonna explain this to anybody
how do you put this into words
oh
i don't want it if you're giving that to
me i really don't want it no
thank you
no
thank you i'm good i've curl those
fingies back up and grasp that tightly
put it right back in your head i'm
hoping that's your head
okay
oh
i love it
thank you
this is so
delightful oh you shouldn't have you
shouldn't have you shouldn't have
oh
great
okay got it
oh my god no
i'm
fine everything is good
there's a ball
when ball is life you have to chase ball
and here we go again
back on this roller coaster nightmare
oh i wonder what this could be oh i
wonder what monstrosity in the darkness
is going to illuminate and reveal
oh
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
oh no okay
what
ah
hello everybody
hello
okay so i need to put my hands on my his
hands not mine definitely not mine
oh don't do it whatever you're thinking
of doing is a bad doing
don't do it
[Music]
oh no
oh it's fine
it's fine i thought you were going to
rip your own i mean i guess technically
you did rip your own head off
i'll take that ball
how do i
ah
i see
okay
i
hate
this song i hate it all i hate it all
oh my god
don't do
anything to me or i will scream
[Music]
okay
this is fine
okay this is fine
this is 100 fun
this is so fine
oh so fine
this kid i want a whiny brat you know
what i mean
someone going through some drama
[Music]
when ball is life
all this beautiful ball is good
ball is everything the shadow people
aren't real the shadow people aren't
real there's always bald
ball is with you inside and out the
shadow people are not inside you
ball is life
ball is everything
[Music]
okay
i'ma step on this i did the thing oh
it's all my toys
hi
so everything's missing a piece oh hi
hey friend ah yeah you
drummer you ride your horsey
woody
okay he's really okay oh he went too
hard
okay
well this is clear what this goes to
train
sounded like a train
god i'm smart
[Music]
i see i see i see i see oh
it was just the illusion of something
bedtime stories i don't know what i just
got
[Music]
ah good car wind up
winder up
[Music]
oh where'd you get that
where'd you get that
interesting
[Music]
i see i see
i don't think it's stopping any closer
maybe i'm supposed to give it to the kid
maybe
take it kid take it oh you got it
[Music]
okay it's fine okay good
and wham
oh
puppy
oh okay
fascinating
okay thank you
that's just what i needed
this is so
uncomfortable
oh wow
oh boy oh oh
interesting
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right could you show mu's boss
hi bunny
[Music]
okay bye bunny
okay oh no i like this less i like this
less
i like that more
i do like that more
i like that less
i don't even know what's going on there
well that's not right
no that's not right
hmm
okay
oh
i think i like that one the least
okay so i'm assuming i'm supposed to get
to the the kid head
which seems like it's supposed to go on
to something
can you hold that thank you that one
seems important
okay doll that's right there was a doll
yeah good we always love dolls in these
horror games
i didn't mean that
i'm sorry for disturbing your peace
yes sorry apparently i need this
[Music]
great do i have to solve this because i
i don't know if i'm gonna be able to do
oh
hi this is a different game
okay
[Music]
you cheater you cheated you cheated
you cheated
[Music]
how could you cheat me it's under your
hat
[Music]
i'll take that thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you thank you
oh
no
why must i torment this duck
[Music]
it's got no more blood left
oh
no
put that back that goes back in the pile
of blood that goes back
how you doing hey oh hi
you got a block
[Music]
wow
okay
thank you for that
[Music]
and what secrets do you have in store
okay
what
i thought that was dynamite
was that supposed to be like a clue or
something was i supposed to know what
that was
[Music]
i too
i to candle
[Music]
i see
so it's some kind of a puzzle
oh
it was that easy huh
[Music]
okay got it
oh wow he's really funky now
[Music]
i don't know when it's gonna happen oh
got it nailed it by that much because
i'm the best and that didn't take me
forever
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
[Music]
here i am
on the boulevard of broken dreams
oh please don't follow me spikes please
don't
that's fine
i'll take that ball
yeah that was the wrong move
what kind of leap of faith is
this baller
[Music]
[Applause]
it was nothing don't even worry about it
keep on playing
yeah way to go big giant sperm monster
[Music]
okay now this is what i saw when i first
saw this game
i was like oh look at all the pretty
visuals with slightly creepy graphics
and then them oh horrible nightmares
nothing but nightmare pure nightmare
100 nightmare
even this is probably 100 nightmares
wow
okay
hi
yeah let's be friends
[Music]
so you don't like anyone yang dangling
on your bell is that what i'm is that
what i'm understanding
[Music]
hi
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
what a fun dream
i'm guessing the answer is don't uh
don't uh
get eaten
okay salute
[Music]
i guess i'll try what i did before again
because that worked out so effectively
for me
i'm gonna ring this
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah runnings from the
get-go is good okay but
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so it's got to be something
about going the other way right there's
got to be something about that
oh
carrots i see
i see
oh oh oh god oh god
hey hey hey
what is what is this all about
okay hang on all right okay it must be
something like this
[Music]
okay where's my
oh but uh oh i gotta give it to them
i see i see i see i see i see
i see
i know what i'm doing you gotta let me
do it you gotta give me a chance you
gotta give me let me understand i could
have elixion edit out all my mistakes i
could have it happen
he'd do that for me
i know he would
right
you'd do that for me
you get that one
[Music]
excellent okay now you're fat
and rotund
oh but where they get a
important
i see i see
i probably needed all three of them to
be in a good position to be at
[Music]
okay yeah so i might have goofed it
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know if i'm gonna make it i
don't know if i'm gonna make it to that
last bunny i don't think i'm gonna make
it to the last bunny
no
[Music]
god damn it of course i did
the curse that didn't make it shut shush
it's a good-looking lick scene it's
gonna cover all my mistakes that's a
good thing it's not gonna make me look
stupid in front of the only internet
no no no you come here you come here
buddy you come here buddy bunny you
sacrificial bunny
come here yeah yeah you know you want it
it's delicious carrot
perfect just as i always plan the whole
day hey oh look at the happy oh
you're happy now
oh you were crying for me
[Music]
okay still a little sad
[Applause]
[Music]
and i've made it oh
oh good oh good
hi bunnies
hi bones
how's it going guys good to see you
[Music]
i'm guessing we get to do something
similar wow
[Music]
wow uh i don't know if i want to press
that just yet oh
my goodness
oh my god okay so i think i know what
that does
ah
i see interesting okay okay yeah yeah
you want to be right
no no no do you want to be right there
no you don't want to be right there
you're going to be right
maybe
[Music]
interesting but i feel like i'm going to
need more time okay let's just activate
it because i know i'm i know this ain't
right but i just want to see if there's
any different behavior from the big guy
which there probably isn't i don't know
why there would be
oh no this ain't good
[Music]
ah big bounces
oh
as i suspected okay here's a thought
here's a crazy thought what if i chop
this bunny after it's been
you know what i mean excuse this
experiment just experiment i'm just
spearman
[Music]
look at that
what we got two fat bunnies
how does that work
poo bunnies
you need another bunny friend
where am i going what am i doing oh i'm
helping
oh
now you need another bunny friend that
you do and that's why they put two
carrots here who wants a carrot
that's right yeah you do
i know you do wait right there can you
both not be there because i feel like
nah wait no one will go away
[Music]
man hope this works the same way as it
did before which is a completely logical
way for it to work here we go
perfect now we're gonna get it
[Music]
oh
well i can't do anything about it right
now so i'm guessing i'm gonna have to
chop it up
come help me
[Music]
oh
all right well
imaginative and ambitious
oh oh oh oh oh oh
boy
wow
okay i guess we're happy now i think
this might be more than the other that
big one can chew
[Music]
oh
hey
check that thing out
[Music]
oh wow
oh wow you just you really downed that
oh you skipped right over the other ones
i feel like i could have done something
to chop you in half but apparently
it's not a necessity at this point
oh good oh more hey
hi guys
how are you doing
hey good to see you hey my name's
markiplier uh
i run a youtube channel i have a podcast
with my bros
um
i hate it here i hate it here
basket get in the basket
you're gonna get in the basket okay
whoa
okay
[Music]
okay um
hey
how are you sorry hey can you hold that
okay oh you got that okay
oh hey
what's wrong
[Music]
oh oh hey
hey big guy
okay
[Music]
okay music um
yeah
that's great man i'm so
confused
ah
you go in the basket
whoa there we go
i'm
oh my god the colors
oh good that one's fun now
hi birds you're new i don't remember
seeing you here before
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
oh it's like a talent show
this is nice
wow
good stuff
[Music]
whoa
nice
that's great you look strong enough to
be up here
wow look at you oh my god okay so now
you there's something here for us to do
what if we put you on this ring oh
that's fun
oh there we go
you in the pool
okay we're just missing one more play
date
[Music]
ah
there you go
oui
with only minor casualties we have done
it magically
i feel so good about myself and all of
the decisions that i've made i can't
wait to see how this is going to turn
out good for all of us
[Music]
oh i hate that one the most
oh
god
[Music]
oh god
oh no
oh why did i do that
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
what a lovely game
oh what a wonderful time
that we're all having here i'm back now
i guess the crows knew what was up
look at the smile on my face mission
accomplished
[Music]
oh
don't do that what i wouldn't this okay
it seemed like a bad idea but whatever
[Music]
oh
yeah that's better
[Music]
well i told you that it wasn't the best
idea
[Music]
friend
oh okay can i have that
[Music]
oh boy yeah this is fitting look
oh hi
what's uh going on in there
[Music]
i don't get it okay thank you for that
that's good advice
i'll take that into consideration hi
forky
oh
[Music]
thank you
thank you for that
i have a fork now you want a fork
[Music]
and a knife
no you can't have both
interesting
what
what was that
you run that by me again
thanks
so i just need to figure out what i need
wait do you need
ah
so you had
yeah i think that was you fork
then you were a knife yeah yeah okay
okay
okay i get it
i don't get the cosmic sense of what
this is all about but i get what this is
i understand you
go for it team
[Music]
oh
i see i see i see i see i see i see
i
[Music]
i might have been wrong about that one
okay all right so your knife
your salt your fork
because you're gonna cut it first and
then season it and then you're gonna eat
it
[Music]
there you go there you go there is that
my head by the way i should have asked
that sooner oh
oh
[Music]
and why why did i do that
no okay okay okay okay
[Music]
oh okay
i think i need something else but i'm
not sure what
oh the pl oh
the plate the plot ah for some reason my
brain just scrubbed that out of
existence
right
put that on there jump on there
i feel like i should be on that thing
don't worry guys i got it my brain's
working at 110 capacity
billion iq here
[Music]
tada i made it
with only a slight delay in what i was
supposed to do so everyone just bear
with me
i've got this
oh god
oh hi that's not right
hi
no come back definitely don't do a
shadow clone of mine oh
wait
you might want to not go forward
oh
boy
um my dude my dude my jam my dude my
dude my dude my dude my dude my dude my
dude my dude my dude my dude my dude oh
boy my dude
[Music]
okay
well that's not a good idea to go that
way
oh well this isn't a good idea to go
this way either
okay well i guess i'm screwed
hi bud i know what's gonna happen but
[Music]
oh
okay this is normal this is fine
ah this was to be expected
okay
oh
[Music]
oh i know what's going on
this commentary is enlightening
[Music]
i did it apparently
oh
good as new
[Music]
oh hi again all right well that was
short lived
[Music]
okay
how
[Music]
uh you want to do a number on me as well
okay
[Music]
oh i see i see okay okay all right this
is what you get
that's what you get
[Music]
oh
your eyes don't look so good
i don't like what you're implementing
that i have to do oh okay
uh you want me to help you
all
right
how is that enjoyable
how is this something that you are
enjoying
i don't like the oh okay oh
oh
what
[Music]
yeah well maybe if you weren't such an
you wouldn't have to deal with
such problems don't expect me to i'm
comforting you now because i'm a good
person
okay
well
oh thank you i somehow my head is still
attached to my body which is an
interesting experience
and there's my body
oh god damn it
uh mine uh mine mine mine not yours mine
mine and not yours
oh my god what are you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right that's all the time i got for
this episode of happy game what a
freaking
mind-bend of an experience but good it's
so weird
but i love it i'm sure there's some
really deep meaning to it but also just
from an experimental level and an art
level it's
this is a ride so thank you everybody so
much for watching there's a link in the
description if you want to play this
game for yourself yeah and let me know
what you thought down in the comments
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you